yes okay this is some serious
[Music]
sauce hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by flee he's a
six-time Grammy award-winning artist
author of The 2019 Memoir acid for the
children a Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
inductee and still going strong with a
pair of number one albums in the last
year and currently on a global stadium
tour but how will a founding member of
The Red Hot Chili Peppers far today
against a flight of blistering spicy
wings we'll find out soon flee welcome
to the show thank you very much for
having me against I don't feel like I'm
going against the wings I'm flowing with
the wings I'm in harmony with the wings
love that attitude I love that attitude
I am one with the
[Music]
[Applause]
wing
[Music]
you know I always pray before I
eat okay here we go as you know I'm a
ritualist we discussed this yes
earlier do the whole thing I
did there we
[Music]
go I feel like with each hot sauce you
have to let it run of of course I mean
hot sauce doesn't always um show itself
on the first taste the first impressions
can be a little misleading that's
someone who's been around the game a
little while yeah I'm not you know it's
not my first uh trip on the hot sauce
car so I know it's Wellborn territory
but remarkable that you and Anthony Kus
have known each other since you were
kids and that the Hot Chili Peppers
formed naturally amongst this group of
tight-knit outcasts from Fairfax High
School in Hollywood yeah from the
Crooked queue to the dilapidated duplex
at Venice and Hower to Harry Houdini's
Mansion is there a jam pad that you look
back on and reflect and and uh remember
most fondly um I'm very impressed with
your knowledge of our of our rehearsal
places the Crooked Q uh was an amazing
spot it was had been a pool hall but it
it was just this like dingy little hole
in the wall down this street in East
Hollywood on heliotrope Street and um I
have a lot of memor in there some like
early early Chili Pepper rehearsals
coming up with their first songs for our
first album and but you know the Harry
Houdini house it was actually not the
Harry Houdini House people call it that
but it was kitty corner across the
street from it and there was there was
rumors that there was a tunnel going
under Laurel Canyon in Hollywood um from
one Mansion to the other during
prohibition they would run liquor and
party and whatever else you know
shanigan they got up to in h jinkx but
um all we had to do was like live in
this place and make music all day and
and and um it was a dream come true for
someone that just wanted to play music
you know um yeah we really finding
ourselves in a an exciting way at that
time it was incredible
house all
[Music]
right processing it yeah lovely uh has a
little depth to it
mhm feeling it it's um light y kind of
fruity maybe yep yep the shashido pepper
is a lovely pepper yep and it has the
kind of sort of savory trail that it
kind of leaves behind there
mhm yeah yeah really nice so while
reading your Memoir I was really taken
by the way that you sentimentalize the
Hollywood Rock clubs of a bygone era is
there an album a specific album that you
think best synthesizes The Angst and
sound of that late 1970s La punk rock
scene um you know I'm very I there are a
lot so for me the big one was the germs
album GI it touched my heart so much and
and made me feel so much emotion and
feeling the same as when I listened to
John col train and I realized that it
doesn't matter how technically brilliant
you are like yes it's great to learn
stuff and the more colors you have to
paint with the more options incredible
but there's something about working with
very simple materials and having a lot
of restraint and being able to express
yourself like Bob Marley always talked
about doesn't matter what kind of music
all it matters is your motivation and
what you're trying to say and um that
really hit home to me when I heard that
germs record so that's a huge record for
me number three I feel like I just you
look have a mischievous [__] look in
your eyes
dude I I wouldn't lead you anywhere
crazy I wouldn't lead you
[Music]
anywhere there you go I ate like nine t0
for that one I saw that I saw
that so when Dave Gro was on the show he
told this story about how he was
performing at a corporate gig and in the
middle of it decided to just jump into
the hotel pool and then when he got out
of the pool immediately electrocuted
himself when he stepped on the
distortion pedal as a rocker for 40 plus
years yourself what would you say is the
most bizarre or painful injury that
you've ever suffered while performing
I've been hitting ah head with a flying
bottle back in the day um I've been spit
on numerous times um you know one time
um Anthony was swinging the mic around
like that and boom clocked me in the
head took me out you know I've hit
myself in the face with my bass yeah
imagine one time I have like a scar in
my head somewhere from I cut my head
open you know like bam like that
um I used to do this I used to I used to
do a flip you know onto my back while I
was playing and that [__] me up a
bunch of times you know of course a lot
of longterm wear and tear from you know
going Going
Bonkers um but honestly to be honest
it's mostly emotional pen
yeah baroa Lo C it's got a kind of a
fearsome looking
bottle
there you go I saw
that got to keep Pace over
here I'm not
scared sitting back relaxed no problem
at
all let it come
down give it to
me so it's interesting to me that after
touring the world and achieving all this
remarkable success that you went back to
to school in 2008 enrolling at USC where
you studied music theory composition and
jazz trumpet how did becoming a literal
student of music influence your approach
to making records like did you recognize
a tangible difference going from the
classroom back into the studio yeah I
had never studied academically you know
beyond the most remedial Basics and I
really wanted to woo the sauce kind of
got a little Ki it got a little staying
power it's fun you know the show that's
how it goes feel I'm feeling it anyways
I yeah I really wanted to to to start
just mix it up you know and always want
to like learn new things to keep me
excited like I've always been completely
turned off by math and then I started
music academically and I started start
kind of loving math like seeing how it
related to music and like how infinite
it is and how far it can go and and um
just being kind of amazed and like
starting to see like how music works
like if you have a note it goes da
that's a sound wave and it say it's
going like that and then then you go an
octave
higher then there's that note up there
is going exactly the soundways exactly
twice as fast you know what I mean so
it's like you
know you know what I mean so and then
all these subdivisions of of sound waves
and and they math them out and Mack them
out and sometimes they become um um
consonant and pleasing to the air and
sometimes they cause tension and sadness
and and a feeling of anxiety and then
you have the tension and then you have
different ways you learn of resolving it
and making makes you feel good because
you get tens and revved up and then ah
you feel good you know Hills and Valleys
and and just kind of like putting a name
and an understanding to all these things
and finding ways to navigate music um
and it was just super healthy for me as
a songwriter as a musician me I would
love to go back and study more I guess
the way to say is it took me from a
place of like working just on emotional
intuition um to also working with um you
know with academics and academics are
beautiful
okay it kind of has Astro Boy on the
cover little psychedelic kind of a
pretty color
whoa yeah starting off pretty
mellow and then it um got a bouquet I
can feel the
bouquet you
[Music]
know feel a little something
something is it true that Circle jerk's
front man Keith Morris he once stepped
in as lead singer for The Red Hot Chili
Peppers at a show in 1984 when Anthony
ketas couldn't make the gig and then
here he is the lead singer of The Red
Hot Chili Peppers does a whole show
doesn't know the lyrics is that true
absolutely true I'm not sure as to like
whole show and how long but he
definitely did it I remember he came out
and we just played some funk grooves and
because we were going to get paid we
showed up do the gig and it was like 50
bucks a piece and I was like no way not
going to play this show and um I just
remember he put put your put your left
hand in your underwear put your right
hand in the air and scream yeah
scream and that's all he did the whole
time and and he you know but did it with
great
enthusiasm and then the show was done
we're back in a dressing room and kind
of like well we did it but also kind of
like where the [__] is Anthony you know
he didn't show up but Anthony showed up
he's like what's up guys let's do the
show we're like who did the
show
is this like the back nine and the
Masters holy [__] it's it's a hot sauce
h u t yeah yeah yeah it's a high level
label over here you know it's like a
nice bottle of wine or
something walk in the
park can't burn me I'm not scared of
anything can't bring
[Laughter]
me what makes the trumpet as you call it
the king of instruments um well I think
it was the king of instruments until the
elect guitar came along the electric
guitar came along with a fuz pedal and a
marshall you know and trumpet players
were kind of [__] um but um you know
it's before the electric guitar it was
the loudest the brightest
um could soar above everything else the
trumpet is just a beautiful thing I play
my trumpet every day you called it a
spokesman for the Divine yeah well all
you know and yeah thanks for so much for
reading my book I yeah yeah well we have
to yeah oh cool we have to did your work
man I appreciate it but yeah you know
it's like this the immediate thing of
this thing and it's kind of like a cold
metal valves Hol spit oil you know and
you kind of warm it up it becomes an
extension of you and it becomes this
warm like beautiful thing you know and
the more you do it the more it just like
this direct expression from you your
heart like it's breath man it's so
beautiful the wind instruments are just
so
awesome okay are we going to eat the
whole thing or are we going to take a
bite I'm going to go wherever you go
oh
yeah I feel like you know when you have
a little baby I have a little baby and
you give them lemon and they like you
know they they go like that and then but
then they want more after I feel like
that's what's going to happened that's
kind of where you're you're at with hot
sauce yeah yeah so I've heard you say
that most songs begin with a baseline is
that just standard practice to set the
tempo are there subtle ways that you're
able to shape the spirit of a song with
that opening Gambit many times did you
you start with baselines and woo had hot
sauce
serious yes whoa It's really it's still
flowing through my you you feel it and
it's going to just build kind of from
here you know yeah yeah yeah we're we're
a rocket ship and we're just taking off
over here F this is like a you know this
is fuel it's got some staying power um
yeah I mean you know if a song starts
with a
baseline um there's a lot of uh it's
cool because a baseline can infer Melody
it can infer chords and it's nice that
it's something that leaves so much open
and so much empty space to be
interpreted and discovered writing music
is so fun oh my God it's so fun it's
like that you know just the act of doing
it sitting down and being lost and kind
of like I always for me it's like the
drool test if I'm playing something and
I just haven't been thinking and I see
like a big Jewel coming down in my shirt
that's a sweet spot that's a good spot
that means I'm just like you know what I
mean whatever I'm doing is so hypnotic
that I'm just vibrating to the point
where I'm drooling it's like I took a
sleeping pill or something you know well
on the topic of vibrating and drooling
yes this next hot sauce is the bomb
Beyond Insanity now I've heard about
this our Nanny Rachel just told me cuz
she's seen this show a lot and she said
see that short one yeah yeah the short
bottle is going to be the one that's
going to [__] you up so what are we
going to do here how are we going to
handle this give it to me straight soft
pedalist I won't I won't this is me uh
just leveling maybe we start with one
bite
if right right more than half yeah I
think it's a good place to start and
we'll see where it goes from there on my
lips where my trumpet
lips
feel it already feel it already
Sean Sean if I need you if I need a hug
I'm here for you whatever you need all
right fle we're just in this abstract
hot sauce storm right now yeah whatever
we need to get through it okay and I'm
here for you this is well it's building
yeah it's not going to stop the rocket
ship is taken off it's building and we
don't know where it's going to go it is
building I know I know what did you do
today how was you warning
where do you live I live here in New
York yeah yeah yeah you live alone I do
uh no no I travel a little bit too much
but I kind of have a puppy fever thing
going on right now puppies are good I
was looking at them online
yesterday yes okay this is some serious
sauce yeah yeah this is for real this is
for Real you're you got good
information
serious Rachel you were right she did
not lie she did not
lie so know that outside of Music you're
a lifelong Hooper you've always sought
basketball as an outlet I love
basketball a season is about to start
are you excited do you like basketball I
do I Love Basketball live for it what's
your alltime Lakers starting five Magic
Johnson Kem Abdul Jabar Kobe
Bryant Michael Cooper Joey West said it
Stone do you have an all-time favorite
or most enduring Rock and jock memory is
it cheating to take a drink it's not
cheating to take a drink go ahead and
take won threo shoot off was my my
favorite
time you hit like six in a RVP and
MVP who was MVP me fle was MVP who
drained a [__] 10-pointer which is
further than a three-pointer on an
assist from Mitch Richmond in the waning
seconds of the game to put [__] Marky
Mark to shame me that's
who
W yeah man it was so fun that was a
really fun day this was a great time
Great era they got to bring that back
but I don't even know if something like
that could even exist anymore they don't
have anymore they have like NBA
Celebrity gam yeah but that's not the
same The Rock The Rock and jock hit on a
it was like kind of culturally Kind of
Perfect you know and I'm better now than
I was then give me a chance put me in I
went played the NBA Celebrity Game like
few years ago they didn't [__] play
me what they didn't play me I said
didn't they see the rocket jock tape
they see that remember my coach was but
I was
pissed woo it's the back it's the back
of the tongue and the
larynx you're right the
Ln is great larynx for your C got x-ray
specs y y
y a sauce was nothing didn't even knock
you off the I'm just feeling emotional
about the pocy of the
moment all right so this next one is
pile on huh cumulative effect there's no
escaping
hopefully
okay going
in yeah ma'am I know runny nose tearing
eyes but we're so close to the finish
line here so close I'm good what's an
enduring memory you have of giving a
music lesson to Koco the Gorilla whose
grasp of sign language inspired so many
documentaries and academic research well
you can't say that Coco smelt so
great I would say that Coco is very
sexual with me obsessed with nipples
I've read about nipples it's going for
my nipple the whole time and they were
like Coco and then so I'm having the
greatest time right I'm like Dr ditt
with this gorilla that sauce is serious
and you tried to check me no but not
like the other one not like the other
one flee I'd never I would never lie to
you I would never lie to
you um Coco so I've always loved Coco
since the First National Geographic
articles that were like in the 80s with
Coco with her kitten Coco's kitten I'd
always been amazed and um the idea of
being able to communicate with an animal
really exciting and um so I go meet Coco
they tell me she might not want you to
come in so I'm kind of outside her
enclosure woo and I'm talking to Coco
and they said you know talk to her like
she really likes to be complimented and
I have my Bas I'm like buet bu I'm like
Coco you are so beautiful oh my God you
look so beautiful Your Eyes your face
your whole body you're so beautiful and
she starts going like doing a heart sign
and come in whatever the sign was all
the stuff come in come see me I'm
excited I go in she's embracing me but
she understood English really well well
even though she couldn't speak it and
there was much stuff that she couldn't
sign she understood everything that was
going to be said and so at one point
we're getting towards end and I had a
flight and I was like said to her to her
uh carer I said um I've got a flight at
3:30 so I got to get going soon and and
um and I you know that I you know and
and just went like that you know like a
little kid like like I don't want you to
go you know what I mean like was like
amazing and she was really like
everything that was being said she
understood
good all right
[Music]
flea so I'm opening up and dabbing you
don't have to if you don't want to who
do you think I
[Laughter]
[Music]
am cheers Bottoms Up B scratch it and
Down the Hatch what you
said
now not easy but the good news flee the
wings of death they're behind us and you
know through this whole spice Journey
we've seen the way that music has shaped
your life beginning when you're in
school playing the trumpet and the
orchestra then of course it evolves into
this insane career and then later on
founding the Silver Lake Conservatory of
Music a nonprofit that offers lessons to
musicians of all skill levels as someone
who obviously cares deeply what letter
grade would you give to the current
state of music education in America and
what do you think is lost when we stop
supporting programs of the Arts um I
think that stopping programs of the Arts
in public schools are making it so only
um people who can afford it can get them
and be exposed to them is like child
abuse I think that all kids should be
have the opportunity to study art at the
highest level um it will make our
society so much better it will build
Bridges of love between all different
cultures and economic classes and bring
people together and um that's what I
care about that's my driving force and
being alive each day it's my life's
Mission and um just working in
communities low-income communities all
different types of places and wanting to
uh you know to be of assistance and
nothing else makes me happier nothing
nothing Well flee what an amazing
journey it has been with you today and
now there is nothing left to do but roll
out the R Carpet for you flee this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your
life um the red carp for oh for me I you
know my life is a ever evolving thing
I'm a humble student of the world I uh
like I said I just want to build bridges
of love in the world I want to play
music I want to make art um I want to
connect connect with people and do
beautiful things I'm a yearner I care
you know I want to keep
[Music]
Bruin did so
good yeah the one was hot like it was
seriously hot but when I I did the one I
watched the Jennifer Lawrence one she
started crying what do you mean what do
you mean what do you
mean you did so good oh thanks man yeah
thank you really cool
chill hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and if you would like
to get your hands on the Season 22 hot
Ones hot sauce lineup at this point you
know the drill heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the hot ones Season 22 hot sauce lineup
ice cream not included be careful around
the eyes don't say I didn't warn you